today on the matt walsh show meghan
markle seeks to crown herself queen
victim
also five headlines including pepe lepew
getting the me to treatment
the media freaks out about spring break
for a second year in a row and a medical
ethicist quote unquote
argues that people who do not get
vaccinated should not be allowed to
participate in society at all
and our daily cancellation we'll discuss
gop house house leader kevin mccarthy
making a stand against cancel culture by
reading green eggs and ham
is this a meaningful symbolic gesture or
just more hollow
right-wing virtue signaling we'll
discuss that and much more today on the
matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
well welcome again to the show before we
get going today i wanted to thank you
for watching and ask you if you enjoy
the show
and want to keep watching or listening
to it please help the show out
fortunately helping us out is very
simple and free if you're listening on
itunes simply give the show a
five-star rating if you're watching on
youtube hit like leave a comment
subscribe hit the notification bell
it sounds like a lot but it takes about
30 seconds i think and no matter how
you're engaging with the show remember
to share it on social media share it
with your friends shout about it from
the rooftops
whatever you can do to get the word out
that's how you can help if you so desire
now
we begin today with prince harry and
meghan
markle um i must confess at the outset
that i don't really care at all about
the royal family or
any of their drama and i have never been
able to understand why anyone does care
the fact that people
are so interested is what has become
interesting to me maybe that's how we
all get sucked in i don't know it's like
walking by
and noticing a group of people staring
at the ground and watching grass grow
and then you stop and you stare at the
people who are staring
fascinated by the fact that they're so
fascinated then the next group stops and
they start staring at you
and on and on until a million people are
staring aimlessly not exactly sure what
they're looking at or why
now i admit that this comparison is
probably a little unfair
to grass um grass may be decorative like
the royal family but it's also
functional
unlike the royal family in any event
as you probably heard two of these
functionless boring people
meghan markle and prince harry split off
from our
royal family a year ago and what many
said was a heroic and brave decision on
their part
came here to america you know they said
they wanted privacy and space to
themselves
those are certainly respectable things
to desire you know
and they could have had both of those
things too if they really wanted them
they could have retreated to a cabin in
the wilderness
dropped out of public eye lived lives of
private solitude and reflection
but the ironic thing is that only
interesting
and substantive people can live a life
like that
like to live a life that seems boring
like that you have to be an interesting
person
as we've established those are not the
kinds of people we're dealing with here
so harry and megan courageously stepped
away from the pomp
and circumstance and wealth of celebrity
life overseas
only to embrace the pomp and
circumstance and wealth of celebrity
life in america
they purchased a 15 million dollar
mansion in southern california
signed a multi-million dollar deal with
netflix and then another one with
spotify
meghan markle says that she bought the
mansion in california so that she could
live authentically and quote get back to
basics
sure well you know you know what they
say one man's basics is another man's
obscene wealth
now you might say that using the term
back to basics in reference to a 15
million dollar mansion
shows an incomprehensible level of
privilege
and you'd be right except that we've
learned the word privilege in our
culture has
absolutely nothing to do with privilege
just as victimhood
has absolutely nothing to do with actual
victimhood
and speaking of victimhood as part of
this effort to live a humble
basic life in their 18 000 square foot
mansion with nine bedrooms and 16
bathrooms
what the hell are you going to do with
16 bathrooms i have no idea
and in pursuit of privacy the netflix
stars did a major prime time interview
with oprah winfrey which aired last
night
during this interview the celebrity
couple reclining on their patio that
probably costs more than your house
explained in great detail why they are
victims
especially megan who um chose to leave
her
life as a hollywood actress after
leaving her husband her first husband
and then marry a member of the british
royal family this was her decision
everyone knows the drama and scrutiny
scrutiny that comes with
that sort of existence even i know it
and i follow this stuff about as little
as a person in modern western society
can follow it i don't even know all
their names
charles is that the old one or the much
older one i don't know
and she certainly knew this too yet she
desired fame and wealth enough to jump
right into it
and then immediately became a victim of
the very thing she was pursuing
but it's not her fault you see yes
everyone who's in the public eye on that
level gets criticized
but it was different for her so much
worse for one thing
people were mean to her on the internet
that's very different none of us know
what that's like
and she explained this more to oprah
listen because
this was different you know no
difference because different because of
the race
and social media and social media oh yes
different times
different time that didn't exist and so
it was like the wild wild west it was
spread like
wildfire plus by being american it
translated in a different way
across the pond so you had a noise level
that was
very different but if they can't see
that it's different
so you felt bullied on an international
level
look i think the i think the volume of
what was coming in and the interest
was greater because of social media
because of the fact that i was not just
british
and that unfortunately if members of his
family say well this is what's happened
to all of us or if
you know if
if they can compare what the experience
that i went through was similar to
what has been shared with us kate was
called weighty katie
waiting to marry william while i imagine
that was really hard and i do i can't
picture what that felt like this is not
the same
and if a member of his family will
comfortably say we've all had to deal
with things that are rude
rude and racist are not the same ah yes
the internet
different type i don't know why i
laughed the first time i saw that
there's something about that line from
oprah that made me laugh
the first time i i saw it when megan
says well it's different because the
internet
and oprah says ah yes the internet
different time
and meanwhile you've got you've got
harry sitting there what kind of man
you know i'm focusing here on meghan
markle but what kind of man
uh brings his wife in front of an
oprah for a major interview to to bash
your family
what kind of my what kind of man finds
that acceptable what kind of man goes
along with that
no way in hell as a man can you go along
with that
your wife says you know i want to do a
major interview where i just or i just
rip your family to pieces
your response should be hell no that's
not happening you're not doing that
we're gonna have no part of that that's
not how we handle problems with the
family
but anyway meghan markle is a victim uh
she's bullied she's a victim of bullying
uh many of us would love to be so
bullied personally
i'd be thrilled to experience this kind
of bullying that ends with me sitting in
my california mansion with a netflix
deal
i've never had the good fortune of being
victimized in that way and i'm beginning
to fear that i may never
i may never have it but it's different
for me though because i'm white
whereas megan is only mostly white and
that means that she can claim victor
victimhood on explicitly racial grounds
as she also did
with oprah let's listen to that concerns
and conversations about how dark his
skin might be when he's born
what and
who who is having that conversation
with you
what so um
there is a conversation hold it hold up
there are several differences there are
several conversations there's a
conversation
with you with harry about
how dark your baby is going to be
potentially and what that would mean or
look like
and you're not going to tell me who had
the conversation
i think that would be very damaging to
them okay
okay ma well we'll move on then i
people are raving about oprah's oprah's
another one talk about things i don't
understand why people are so interested
i've never quite
understood um how oprah ever became
the big thing that she is you know i
it's
it's a fine that's that's like the kind
of standard entertainment
sort of interview that you would expect
to see but i think anyone in media could
do that
um that's that's her follow-up so
meghan markle makes this this incredible
claim
oprah says what that's something else
who said it oh i don't want to say
because it'd be damaging to them well
okay moving on so she never clarified
who made that alleged comment
what this means is that either megan
made it up
distinct possibility or someone did say
it and she's happy to throw the whole
family under the bus
as the press wildly speculates as to the
culprit
rather than simply naming the person who
said it
either way in handling it the way she
did she's not much better morally
than the person who made the comment to
begin with even if that person is
fictional
and also either way megan meghan markle
is a fabulously rich and famous person
who has gone to great lengths to be both
of those things rich and famous
and who now wants to have her mansion
and cry in it too
she gets away with it the ruse pays off
because this is how victimhood works in
america and that's the one interesting
or at least important thing to come out
of this whole story and why it's worth
talking about
because victimhood is the primary social
currency in our culture today
and meghan markle seeks to become like
the jeff bezos of that currency the bill
gates of victimhood
she has been making and is going to make
a career out of being a victim
the rules of intersectionality make that
possible for her all the royals and all
the people affiliated
with them are insufferable spoiled brats
harry and megan are no different but
megan is the least
white and so she gets to be the victim
those are the rules
if she was in a dispute with someone who
was less white than her or
who could lay claim to one of the
letters in the lgbt acronym
then she'd be the villain the details of
the dispute don't matter
actual right and wrong don't matter
intersectionality is what matters and
lucky for her she's publicly dumping on
people who are
rich and powerful obviously yet further
down the intersection
the intersectionality ladder than
herself
and that's the way the game works it
really is that simple
but it's important for us to see how
victimhood works
because this is what this is what drives
the culture now this has
as i said the the currency our culture's
currency is victimhood
so she at least is demonstrating that
for us
now i'll go back to not caring about
these people
again let's get now to our five
[Music]
headlines
before we get to five headlines today
you know it's so important these days
it's always been important but uh it's
especially important these days to
make sure that we are supporting
companies that have
morals to support companies that support
us in the culture that are working on
our side in the culture rather than
undermining us even as we give the money
which is so often the case and a lot of
that is unavoidable but thankfully
there's charity mobile
that's one company at least that fits
the description of being a company with
morals charity mobile the pro-life phone
company
five percent of your monthly plan price
goes to the pro-life pro family charity
of your choice
new activations and eligible accounts
get a free cell phone with free
activation and free shipping so
uh that means that you know they're on
top of the great the great uh
uh you know charity that they do the
great work that they do in the culture
is also a really good service that
you're getting as well
no contracts no termination fees and
there's no risk with a 30-day guarantee
what that means is you might as well
go with charity mobile try it out you're
not getting you're not getting locked
into anything
and i think that if you try it you'll
discover that you love it i've been
using charity mobile for many months now
and i have nothing but good things to
say about it and they've got live
customer service based right here in the
usa so that's american jobs on top of it
but the main thing as far as i'm
concerned you're helping to build a
culture of life in america while
supporting a pro-life
phone company on top of all that you get
nationwide service on america's
largest and most reliable 4g lte network
so it's a win-win-win
all the way around call them at
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com by the way today is
uh i'd be remiss if i didn't mention i
think today
is international women's day i believe
um i always have it marked out on my
calendar i don't know why i forgot to
mark it down this time
but uh big big deal international
women's day
uh and so today is the beginning of
international women's
week um and it's international it's
international
women's day which is the beginning of
international women's week
and which falls in the middle of women's
history month
so we got all that going on all of that
all of that affirmation um
for women and and you know every woman
that i personally know
doesn't desire any of that affirmation
or care about it
but whether you want it or care about it
there it is you have it you are affirmed
ladies all right um number one charles
blow
new york times columnist wrote a piece a
few days ago defending the cancellation
of dr
seuss and adding a few more
um a few more people to to to cancel to
to the burn pile
or not really people actually he's now
we're going to cartoons we've done dr
seuss canceling dr seuss books um
and now and we've already done the
muppets
okay so they're canceled they're but
they're puppets
so we've gone from there and now we're
going all the way to the cartoon
characters he also called for the
cancellation
of speedy gonzalez and pepe le pew both
of
looney tunes fame now
um it's it's been an interesting
reaction to both of these things
because he mentioned that speedy
gonzales is insulting because it's a
it's a you know hispanic stereotype
and now there have been a lot of uh
latino people coming out
you know including celebrities um
gabriel iglesias who's the uh hispanic
comedian he's gonna be voicing speed
gonzales in the new space jam
and he came out and they said we we love
speedy gonzales
which what yeah why why would if you're
up if you're a hispanic child
growing up especially back when looney
tunes was more popular
why wouldn't you love speedy gonzales
he's he's the hero he's one of the good
guys right if i remember my
looney tunes mythology if i'm getting it
correct then then he's
always one of the good guys speeding as
alice is
so what's the problem exactly
you can say oh it's a it's a stereotype
it's a caricature well it's a cartoon
of course it's both of those things
yosemite sam is a caricature elmer fudd
is a caricature
but isn't it also representation isn't
it isn't that what we
want see the left can never make up its
mind are we doing
are we getting rid of
all of these representations of minority
characters and minority culture are we
getting rid of all that stuff
or should we have more of it which is it
it can't really be both
so speeding in zealous would seem to be
representation you would think it'd be
the kind of thing that the left would
celebrate but we were told we have to
cancel
them and also pepe le pew um
who uh charles blow argue argues
normalizes rape culture
because as you remember if you if you
can think back to watching looney tunes
pepe le pew
um you know uh a rather
a a a a skunk who you know has
voracious sexual appetites um
and is always pursuing in particular i
think it was a black and white cat that
he always
that always confuses with a skunk and
he's always pursuing this this female
cat
but the thing is he always loses she
always gets away
and he's not the good guy we're not
supposed to empathize
the the the message in looney tunes
isn't that we should empathize
with uh with with pepe lupio he's absurd
it's ridiculous
the kids watch that and they think it's
ridiculous they laugh at it
which is a good message now the main
message because it's a cartoon it's
looney tunes the main message is this is
all silly and ridiculous
and don't take it too seriously but if
you are going to take it seriously then
the real
then if you're looking for a more
serious message
then the message you would take is that
his behavior is bad
don't act like that which is why i could
be wrong
but uh in spite of charles blows claims
you know i don't think it's it's very
often that you hear of sex offenders who
cite pepe le pew
as one of their primary influences could
be wrong i haven't really
i haven't looked into this haven't
researched it but i'm guessing that if i
did you're going to very rarely find
a real life rapist or sex offender who
says that he got into this
into this life because he watched a lot
of pepe le pew cartoons as a child
and by the way if we're finding a reason
for pepe le pew to be offensive
shouldn't it be that he that he's a that
he's a stereotype of the french
isn't if it's a if he's offensive for
any reason isn't that it
he's a french rapist skunk
isn't that offensive to if it's
offensive to anyone
wouldn't it be offensive to french
people
speedy gonzalez is a is a is a
a hero you know he's one of the
protagonist characters
pebble pew is a bad guy basically
um a rapist or attempted
a skunk and he's french
but no see that can't be offensive
because french people are white
stereotypically they're white so so
that's
that's okay we've got to find another
reason for pepe le pew to be offensive
and this is it
um and it doesn't stop there so we're we
are now officially
uh doing a me too with pepe le pew
pebble pew is getting me tood
a cartoon character you thought they
would stop at people but no
no now we're going to cartoon characters
and the hollywood reporter uh has this
it says the controversial looney tunes
skunk cartoon character
popular pew was scrubbed from the lebron
james um
the new lebron james space jams space
space gym
space jam 2 is coming out we just
mentioned uh speedy gonzales is good
still is going to be in space jam 2 as
far as we know but pepe le pew has been
removed
from space gem 2. now they claim that
this decision was made
a year ago so not directly in response
to this new
york times piece that's what they claim
anyway but one way or another he's being
taken out
presumably because he normalizes rape
culture and
he's offensive and not because he's
offensive to french people
uh number two the new york post has this
spring break partying could spell the
perfect storm for triggering the spread
of new coronavirus variants across the
u.s
according to experts dr peter hotez
says it's the perfect storm hotel said
he feared that college kids hitting the
party scene in florida
could accelerate the spread of highly
contagious uk variant which is known as
b117
he said quote you've got the b117
variant accelerating in florida
you've got all these 20 year old kids
none of them are going to have masks
they're all going to be drinking they're
having pretty close intimate contact
and then after all that's done they're
going to go back to their home states
and spread the b117 variant
this is the the new york post story but
there are you know dozens of them in the
media
right now so we really are going to do
the spring break freak out for a second
year in a row we're going to do this
all over again you may recall back last
march
april we did the exact same thing spring
breakers went down to florida
we were told that this is a disaster in
the making
uh it's going to be a bloodbath so many
of these kids are going to end up sick
in the hospital they're going to die and
all these things
and that's not actually what happened if
you recall
we we never got from spring break
we never got the apocalypse we were
promised stemming from spring break
and now so if if if their
panicking ended up being sort of a dud
the first time last year
well now this year the virus is receding
as we can we're getting now into the
warmer
temperatures millions and millions more
people
are immune to it either because they
already had the virus even if they had
it with no symptoms
or because they got the the vaccine
so why would there be more reason to
worry this year than there was last year
well there isn't of course but the media
can't help itself number three from the
blaze it says a democratic new york
lawmaker
introduced a bill to teach comprehensive
sex ed to kindergarteners
the sex education will reportedly be
outsourced to a left-wing organization
that believes quote sex
ed is a vehicle for social change
including incorporating social and
racial justice messaging
into their sex ed lessons new york
senator samra
brock a freshman democrat from rochester
introduced a bill to teach comprehensive
sexuality education in schools including
children
as young as five years old the bill
reads quote each public and charter
school to provide
students in grades kindergarten through
12 with comprehensive sexuality
education
um uh
her proposal the new york post reported
that her proposal would legally link new
york schools to the shifting
recommendations of the
sexuality information and education
council of the united states
this is what's going to determine you
know what your
kids are taught in school when it comes
to sex ed of course in reality
there should be no sex ed of any kind
for kindergarteners
this is part of the ever-present effort
to sexualize
children that we see in our culture
especially in the schools
and i always have to remind people when
we get into this conversation about sex
ed
um and all of the depraved and
disgusting and perverted things
that kids are taught even at young ages
in in
in modern sex ed in this effort to
confuse them we start introducing gender
identity at very young ages
telling the little boys hey if you like
if you like playing with dolls you might
be a girl that kind of thing
but the response in many cases from
conservatives especially christian
conservatives
when they hear about this kind of stuff
is uh well
you know this is why we need abstinence
education instead of
this kind of sex education and my
response to that is no we don't need
that either
you know the antidote to this kind of
depraved sex education
for kids is not well let's let's let's
form a better version of sex ed
no it's neither none of it that's the
answer
schools shouldn't be doing any of this
you want to teach the biology of human
sexuality of course you teach that in
biology class
you want to teach about human anatomy
and what all the different parts of the
body do
um uh including you know the sex organs
well then you
at the appropriate age you teach that in
science class
but in terms of a a message about
sexuality
especially an ethical or moral message
a message about you know what how to
engage in sex and
when to do it and all that kind of stuff
doesn't belong in the schools
no i i don't want if i sent my you know
12 year old to middle school
to public middle school which i wouldn't
but if i did
i don't want their health teacher
telling them
how to use birth control or condoms but
i also
don't want the health teacher to get up
there and and tell my son about the
you know the wonders of of chastity and
abstinence
because i can do that and that's a
really important lesson
um that i do not trust the schools to
impart
that's something that you as a parent
need to do
you know we we we cannot farm everything
out we can't outsource
every aspect of parenting to the schools
and this is a big one
these may be uncomfortable conversations
that people parents don't want to have
with their kids but
if you don't then school's going to do
it and i wouldn't trust the school to do
it
so t that's the answer get all this
stuff out of the school
number four arthur kaplan who's a
professor of quote medical ethics
had some uh medical ethics advice for us
on cnn yesterday let's listen to that
well remember vaccine passports or even
vaccine requirements do
depend on access it's hard to impose
anything unless you
are pretty sure that somebody can get a
vaccine so i think it'll be a little
while before we see this
let's say within the us but they're
going to be communities and areas of the
country where it starts to make sense
due to high availability of vaccine to
say
you want to come back to work in person
got to show me a vaccine certificate you
want to go in a bar
a restaurant got to show me a vaccine
certificate i think there will be some
inequality
in the u.s but hopefully it will wash
out quickly as the supplies
increase very rapidly and i think
they're going to
it also gives you an incentive to
overcome vaccine hesitancy
some people are not sure still whether
they want to do the vaccine but if you
promise them
more mobility more ability to get a job
more ability to get travel that's a very
powerful incentive
to actually achieve fuller vaccination
it will never cease to amaze me to see
how quickly uh the bodily autonomy
argument
has just gone out the window
this has been pretty much the entire
argument for abortion
it's all the left really has when it
comes to abortion and even there it's
not a good argument
but the personhood argument you know and
they've lost all of that because we it's
modern science
very clear uh and you really didn't even
need modern science to tell you that the
the being in the womb of a mother is a
human child
what else could it be what other species
could it be of course it's a living
what else would it be dead inanimate
so they've lost that um that doesn't
mean they won't they won't keep
trying to make claims but but it's a
losing argument so
they go over to bodily autonom autonomy
which is why i'm you know engaging with
the bodily autonomy argument for
abortion all the time
but you know that argument in order for
that to even begin to work for abortion
you have to take an absolutist view on
bodily autonomy
where you say i can do whatever i want
with my body
because it's my body
that's the only way that it even and it
still doesn't work
because the problem is there's someone
else's body immediately concerned here
with abortion it's not really at all
what you're doing with your body it's
what you're doing
to someone else's body that's the issue
that's the whole debate should you be
allowed to
um dismember your child in the womb
stab them in the heart with a with a
poison needle should you be allowed to
do that
but that's whatever your answer is that
is an answer you are giving
in relation to someone else's body not
your own
but even so in order for this argument
to even get started then you have to
take the absolutist view
that um i can do whatever i want with my
body even to the extent that uh
that you know if someone is is reliant
on my body
i can kill them i can i can actually you
know um
violate their own body to the extent of
destroying them
because they depend on my body
so that's the absolutes hardline you
have to draw
in order to get the the wheels in motion
for that argument
but now we've just tossed all that out
the window
with masking laws you know um
the idea of vaccine passports you just
heard from this medical ethicist by the
way i don't know his view on what his
medically ethical view is on abortion i
could guess
what it is
but for the left generally you know
vaccine
passports masking laws
okay if you want to argue for those
things i'm not in favor of them
but if you want to do that then you are
forfeiting bodily autonomy
out the window because in this case you
are telling someone
what they have to do with their own body
not only that they have to wear a
certain thing across their face
but now you're telling them they have to
inject a substance into their body
you want to make that argument go ahead
but bodily autonomy is done
you can't go back to that all right
number five
also from cnn it says the risk of death
from kova 19 is about 10 times higher
in countries where most of the
population is overweight according to a
report released wednesday
by the world obesity federation
researchers found
that by the end of 2020 global kova 19
death rates were more than 10 times
higher in countries
where more than half the adults are
overweight 10 times higher
compared to countries where fewer than
half are overweight
the team examined mortality data from
johns hopkins university and the world
health organization and found that of
2.5 million kova 19 deaths reported by
the end of february 2.2 million
were in countries where half of the
population's overweight analysis of data
and studies from more than 160 countries
the researchers found that covenanted
mortality rates
increased along with countries
prevalence of obesity
and this is important too they note that
the link persisted even after adjusting
for age
and national wealth now this is not
new information we already knew this um
we knew this we knew this back at the
very beginning
that obese people were especially
susceptible
we knew elderly people and obese and if
you're elderly and overweight then then
you're really
in the danger zone so we knew that but
this
link it's something that we've known
it's been reported here and there
kind of scatter shot but it hasn't been
emphasized the way that it should be
and the reason that should be is very
clear that you know we want to make it
clear if you are an overweight person
especially if you're older
you got to be extra special careful
about this
but the reason why the link has not been
emphasized i think two reasons
one is just general fear-mongering you
know the media wants everyone to be
equally as frightened by the virus
uh but also political correctness
they you know they don't be accused of
victim blaming if they
if they go and say that uh you know
obese people are more likely to die of
the virus which is true
then it sounds like you're blaming them
you know for being obese or all these
things so
political correctness hyper drive that's
why
the link is not is not emphasized it's
the same thing that happened with uh
with you know the aids virus
and even now we are often told
or it's strongly implied that uh you
know aids
is a is an equal opportunity
virus it doesn't discriminate whether
you're heterosexual or homosexual you're
just as likely to get that's not true at
all
the majority of people who who get the
virus are homosexual
and then the next biggest chunk would be
intravenous drug users
and then if you if you you know put that
big chunk aside you're left with a very
very small number of cases
and then from there if you take medical
mishaps out of it you know blood
transfusions or
medical equipment that wasn't properly
sterilized you take that out of it and
you're left only with heterosexual
people
who do not use drugs and haven't had any
kind of
medical mishap how many of them are
getting the aids virus
as a percentage very very very
vanishingly small percentage
and that has always been known too but
that reality is
de-emphasized in order to send the
message that
everyone you know is uh is is equally as
susceptible
which also is not true and there's a
real consequence
to de-emphasizing the truth here
because with with aids you know if
you're if you're homosexual engaging in
this kind of
sexual activity there are extra risks
that come with it you want people to
know that
and when it comes to coronavirus if
you're obese and you're also older
yeah there's a reason for you to be even
more concerned than everyone else
that's not to single anybody out or
victim blame it's to keep people safe
and also to simply tell people the truth
and the truth still matters
i think even if the media would disagree
let's get now to our uh
reading the youtube comments section we
got a couple here
pertaining to the show on friday
sebastian says
i'm 15 and even i don't think 16 year
olds should vote
i have to say i saw a lot of comments uh
just like this
kids that are 15 16 17 saying yeah look
i'm i'm in it right now don't let me
vote which i appreciate i appreciate the
the honesty there
ojh says i looked up mick elligott's
pool
dr seuss book and read it online there's
a mention of eskimo fish with little fur
coats unfortunately i am now a racist
bigot as a result of reading it
we're going to talk more about that in a
moment um
but yes if you actually go now it's hard
to do this now because these books have
been erased
but if you have a copy of one of the
band dr seuss books
and you go pick them up you know several
of these books you're going to have a
hard time
figuring out what was offensive about
them and mick elegance pool is
certainly one of them
as far as i can tell and i had the same
thing i had to go back and read it i
found
i found it online anyway or i could
something i could you know the text
online that i could read
um as far as i could tell
what was offensive about that book and
why it's on the banned list
is uh is because it says the word eskimo
we'll talk more about that in just a
second though
doe flamingo don quixote great username
says matt could you give us a breakdown
of what
makeup products you use i'm aspiring to
be tick-tock famous
but i need to not look like a corpse
thank you that look
i admitted you know that i wear makeup
on camera
anyone on camera does i admit that
that's as far as i can i go
we're not at the point now where i'm
giving makeup tutorials
i also have no idea i sit down in the
makeup chair and uh i
you know it's like don't ask don't tell
just do do what you have to do
we're gonna pretend this isn't happening
so i don't know what they put on my face
they put something on there
um and finally not important says
does anyone else salute matt when he
says god speed
to end the show well i assumed everyone
was doing that i
i would demand that kind of reverence
and respect in fact
and obviously if you are not saluting me
at the end of the show then you are
banned now a quick word from our very
good friends
at rock auto listen you know as more and
more of our life migrates online that's
not always
a a good development but one area where
i think it is good
is with rockauto.com and shopping for
auto parts because there's you know
there's there's no real advantage to
getting into your car
which you may be having problems with in
the first place that's why you need the
auto parts you go down to the auto parts
store
uh and you're gonna spend more money
there's gonna be it's not gonna be as
good of a selection you have to answer a
lot of questions you may not know the
answer to
no real advantage when you've got
rockauto.com in your pocket
at your desk on your computer
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible
rather than changing prices based on
what the market will bear like airlines
do
they're their family business they've
been doing this online for 20 years
and they're always going to give you the
best price possible if you find it
at rockauto.com whatever you're looking
for and you'll most likely find it there
what you also can know is that it's the
best price you're going to find amazing
selection reliably low prices all the
parts your car will ever need at
rockauto.com so
go to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car truck
write walsh in there how did you hear
about us box so they know that
we sent you well um also
what if the police could go on strike at
a moment's notice
firefighters the military imagine the
kind of disruption
and chaos that that would create these
are the dangerous scenarios associated
with public sector unions and in the
latest episode of the new series
debunked ben shapiro
breaks down all of the known lies and
platitudes that most people are fed
with regard to unions the latest episode
which dropped this past weekend covers
all of this and more but
you have to be a daily wire member to
watch so go to dailywire.com
subscribe and use code debunked to get
25 off your new membership that's code
debunked
for 25 off at dailywire.com subscribe
now let's get to our daily cancellation
so today we're going to cancel
republican congressman and house
minority leader
kevin mccarthy mccarthy is cancelled
today for engaging in what i would call
right wing virtue signaling right-wing
virtue signaling is
a special sub-genre of virtue signaling
popular among republican politicians
wherein the signaler jumps into a
culture war issue in the hollowest most
superficial and corniest way possible
in order to signal to other
conservatives that he's down with the
cause
even though he isn't really doing
anything to help the cause at all
now perhaps the greatest possible
example of this is what kevin mccarthy
did
a few days ago when he filmed himself
reading
the dr seuss book green eggs and ham
let's check this out
green eggs and ham by dr seuss
i am sam i am sam
sam i am
that's sam i am that sam i am i do not
like
that sam i am do you like green eggs and
ham
i do not like them sam-i-am i do not
like green eggs and ham
would you like them here or there
i would not like them here or there i
would not like them
anywhere i do not like green eggs and
ham
i do not like them sam-i-am
now leaving aside the fact that his
reading voice for children's books needs
a little work reading children's books
is all about and i've done a lot of it
in the last seven years it's all about
rhythm and cadence there's a certain
poetry to it especially with asus book
and all of that is lost in mccarthy's
rendition and he can be canceled just
based on that alone
i'm very picky about the the reading of
children's books
but never mind the real point is that
this is the cringiest
and most pointless display we've seen
from an elected republican in a long
time
why is he reading green eggs and ham
that isn't one of the banned dr seuss
books
nobody has taken issue with green eggs
and ham it doesn't require any courage
or boldness to read that book
it's totally irrelevant it's a signal
not to the left
this is not a signal to the left saying
i will oppose you i'm not afraid of you
that's a good signal to send but the
left doesn't give a damn if you read
green eggs and ham
no this is a signal to the right and the
signal is supposed to be
i'm on your side look at me i've joined
this latest culture war kerfuffle
aren't i such a brave boy but the real
message he sends is
i am afraid to say anything interesting
or valuable about this situation so
instead
i'm going to read from this children's
book that nobody cares about
what he could have done would have
required some guts not much but a little
and would have also had some value is if
he had read one of the banned
dr seuss bugs and the point of doing
that would be first
to just defy the woke mob for the sake
of defying it
and second to demonstrate how political
correctness and wokeness have gone way
overboard and driven everyone insane
he could have read for example as
mentioned earlier mick eligot's pool
which is an actual banned dr seuss book
and the only reason it's banned
so far as i can tell is that it uses the
word eskimo
that's it that's really it but eskimo is
not a slur
it's not a pejorative we don't have to
bleep it out when i'm saying it right
now eskimo you can say that
it's not offensive now it may not be the
popular term to use these days but it's
not a slur
and the idea that it's so offensive that
it needs to be taken off of ebay and
amazon
and taken out of publication by its
publisher because it said eskimo
is simply ludicrous now it would have
been interesting if mccarthy had read
that book in order to make that point
but then he would have had to say the
word eskimo and that would be a little
too edgy for his tastes
i don't want to say that i don't want to
say the e word
or he could have read one of the titles
with offensive imagery
and showed the imagery on camera now
that would have been interesting
and he could have made the point that
people 80 years ago you know didn't have
the same sensibilities that we do today
we can't hold them to a modern standard
or view their work through an entirely
modern lens
he could have done that and that would
have been worthwhile and bold and
interesting but instead
he read green eggs and ham a book that
is not in dispute
and that nobody is talking about yet
reading it is the safe
easy uncontroversial way of dipping your
toe into the culture war battle of the
moment
and that's all we get from elected
republicans a bunch of toes dipping
barely below the surface
and unfortunately people fall for this
stuff that he tweeted that out and they
got like 40
000 or more i think likes and a bunch of
retweets
on twitter you know
for what reason i i know that
among republican voters they might say
well at least he's doing something it's
better than nothing
no it's not better than nothing this is
nothing
and there's going to be a lot of this
sort of thing from here on out
remember the republicans had total
control of the government for two years
they had the white house in the senate
for four years
during that time they did basically
nothing they passed a few
tax cuts plenty of cable news hits
but they didn't advance the conservative
agenda in any significant way
they didn't even try to advance it in
fact they complain now about you know
big tech censorship well why didn't you
do something about it when you had the
power to do it
the same question could be posed about
every subject the republicans whine
about today
they could have passed actual laws set
policy but they preferred as they always
prefer
to bide their time until they're out of
power so they can get back to writing
big
rhetorical checks that they'll never
have to cash that's their specialty
always has been stand on the sideline
and talk a big game
but the moment their number gets called
and they're out on the field in the
starting lineup
all they do is fall to the turf and curl
up in the fetal position
yelling please don't hurt me then when
they're back on the sideline they're
immediately back to you know talking
smack
man i wish they'd put me in there i'd
run somebody over i tell you
the same old song and dance over and
over again i'm not impressed with it
not fooled by it i hope you aren't
either
and that is why kevin mccarthy is
cancelled
green eggs and ham is not canceled uh
it's it's a great book and if if if
you know if the mob ever does come from
grief for green eggs and ham i will be
there to fight for the to the death
on its behalf but uh right now that is
not the subject
that we're talking about so again kevin
mccarthy is canceled
and we'll leave it there today thanks
for watching thanks for listening have a
great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel ledosky the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 joe biden
showers money on americans according to
the washington post top new york
democrats calling andrew cuomo to resign
and meghan markle whines about being a
princess to oprah check it out on the
michael knowles show
[Music]